the idea of concativity will show up a
lot in your calculus class so what i
want to do in this video
connectivity
is one show you what concativity is or
what concave upwards and what concave
downwards is and to have an intuition of
what those mean and then discuss the
ideas of inflection points which are
really just transition points between
being either concave upwards and
downwards or between downwards and
upwards so the two ideas that we'll talk
about
one is being concave
concave
upwards
i'll write that in this column right
here and maybe in
pink i'll write i'll show you what
concave downwards looks like concave
downwards
so very simple
way to think about it is that concave
upwards is kind of a u shape that's why
it's called concave upwards it might
look something like this let me draw
some axes so you know that i'm actually
graphing something and not just drawing
a u
so maybe if that is
my axis right there a concave upwards
graph would look something like this
let me do it in
green
it could look something like this so
this graph and it'll just keep going as
x goes positive and negative the entire
over the entire domain of this function
this is my f of x right here it is
concave upwards and you can see it has
this u shape and i'll discuss in a
second what implication that has for its
slope or what the slope is doing
but this is just very easy to recognize
visually
similarly let me draw an axis again
i want to show you what concave
downwards looks like so let me draw some
axes right there and i'm just drawing an
arbitrary function f of x could be
anywhere it doesn't have to be you know
it's the bottom point doesn't have to be
in the first quadrant like this it's
just the general u-shape i wanted to
show you for concave upwards concave
downwards you could probably guess what
it looks like based on if this is
upwards downwards is going to be
opposite it might look something like
this
it might look something like this so
maybe this is some other function
g of x and notice it looks like an
upside down u over the entire domain of
this function it is concave downwards so
you can look at it and
immediately see oh well if it's if it's
like a u it's upwards if it's like an
upside down u it's downwards but what
does that actually mean for the slope so
to understand that let's think about
what's happening to the slope here so
i'm just going to do it visually so at
that point the slope of the tangent line
or the slope of the actual graph or the
instantaneous slope however you want to
view it let me see how well i could draw
it
it'll look something like that
that's the tangent line then if as we
increase x so that's at this x value
right here right at that x value the
slope looks like that it's fairly
negative now as we increase x maybe we
go to another point right here what
happens the tangent line
will look like this it'll look
like this it's still downward sloping
it's still downward sloping but it's
less downward sloping now right here it
was a very steep downward slope now it's
a less steep downward slope and we can
keep going if we go to this point
we're still downward sloping we're still
downward sloping but even less steep and
that keeps happening we keep getting
less and less downward sloping or
less steep in the downward direction
until until we get to this minimum point
and you've seen this before where our
slope actually gets to zero
and it just keeps increasing it keeps
increasing over here if we go to this
point now we're going where we have a
steep upward increasing as we increase
our x even further the slope at this
point right here
we haven't it's increased even more it's
a steeper upward
upward sloping curve so i want to make
it very clear even though even though if
we go to this left hand point here we
had a very steep downward sloping curve
and as we went up here with upward
sloping
the whole time as our x increased the
whole time as we increased x
as we increased x what was happening to
the slope
the slope was increasing
so as we increased x the slope
the slope increased
and this is the definition of a of a
concave upwards
interval or section of this curve in
this case it's this entire curve i'll
i'll start showing you functions that
mix it up in a little bit over here we
were very negative we became less
negative becoming less negative is the
same thing as increasing even less
negative over here then we were
completely flat zero is a higher slope
than some negative slope here and then
we became positive and more positive and
even more positive so the entire time
our slope is increasing now let's look
at the concave downward scenario
let's start with a relatively low x
maybe right here here we have a pretty
high slope
right at this point we have a very steep
upward slope if as x increases
so we go to a less negative x so x is
increasing we still have an upward slope
but it's less upward so our slope has
decreased and over here it's it's still
an upward sloping curve right it's going
from the bottom left to the top right
but it's flatter it's flattening it's
becoming less positive until we get to
this point i didn't draw the original
curve that well where we get to maybe a
a
a maximum point
because the slope goes to zero and then
we go and as we increase now our slope
becomes negative
it becomes even more negative it becomes
even more negative so as as we kind of
travel as we increase our x
as we increase
increase our x over this curve
our slope decreases
slope is decreasing
slope decreases i want to make that very
clear the slope was very positive this
doesn't mean that the slope is negative
it's just saying that the over the
entire interval the slope continues to
decrease it goes from very positive to
less positive to less positive to zero
to slightly negative to more negative to
very negative so it just decreases the
whole time in concave upwards it
increases the whole time
so let me draw an example that might
have the combination of the two
that might maybe i'll leave this around
just so we can look at it for reference
let me draw
an axis right there not the straightest
line in the world but it'll suit our
purposes
and let me just draw some curve here so
maybe i have something that looks like
that
maybe i have a curve that looks
something like that now over what
interval of this function's domain maybe
i'll call it h of x
is this curve concave upwards or concave
downwards well you could look at it just
from inspection just from
that original definition that i said
that concave upwards is when you're like
a u concave downwards is when you're
like a uh i guess
upside down u
so over here where u from roughly it
looks like a u from roughly this point
onwards right we have this u shape
we have this u shape and maybe the curve
just keeps going on this so from here
onwards
onwards we are concave
let me write it over here
from there onwards we are i don't know
the same color we are concave
concave
upwards
and then
on the interval before that from here on
before this point right here
we are concave downwards
concave downwards you can just recognize
that
and let's look explore what's actually
happening with the slope so over here
the tangent line has a pretty high let
me do a different color
over here the tangent line has a pretty
high positive slope
then it has a less positive then at this
maximum point it goes to zero
then it goes slightly negative even more
negative even more negative so for this
whole time this so up until this point
up until this point the slope
the slope is decreasing which is
completely consistent with what we said
about being concave downwards but then
something interest interesting happens
at a point right about there i'm not
being very accurate or precise right
there but right about there you see that
the slope of the tangent line looks like
that right
and that was more negative than right
here and which was more negative than
right there but over here something
interesting happens all of a sudden
my slope starts to increase again
it starts to i want to draw it let me
draw it as neatly as i could possibly
draw it so over here the slope looks
something like this
the slope looks something like this and
then as we go beyond so if we go
backwards from there if we go
to more negative x's the x's before that
had a less negative slope so the slope
was decreasing but all of a sudden here
when we go here the slope is slightly
higher it's less negative there then
it's even less negative there then it
goes to zero here then it goes slightly
positive and even more positive so up
until this point
in our functions domain our slope was
decreasing our slope was decreasing up
until this point and then after that
point our slope is increasing our slope
is increasing so this point it seems
like we should call it something and we
do call it something this point right
here where we go from concave downwards
to concave upwards and it would actually
be true if it was the other way around
this
is called an inflection point
inflection
point and this would also be called an
inflection point if it was the other way
if we went from a curve let me draw a
curve that looks like this that was
concave upwards and then it's concave
downwards the point that we're switching
the point at which you go from one to
the other essentially your rate of the
change of slopes which is signs that is
an inflection point so this is also an
inflection point
so what does this mean hopefully you
understand
visually what a what concave upwards and
concave downwards means at an inflection
point but what does this mean for the
second derivative
remember the second
the derivative is the rate of change so
let me write this down
so f of x that's just the function right
that's just the function that's what
we've been graphing
f prime of x
that's the slope of the function
slope of function at any point x
you've seen that multiple times already
what's the second derivative
well you could view it as the derivative
of the first derivative right that's the
slope of the slope or the rate of change
rate of change
of
of the slope itself so what did we say
about concave upwards
concave upwards is when the slope is
increasing which means that the rate of
change of the slope is positive
well that what that means is that the
second derivative which is the slope of
the slope f prime of x is going to be
greater than zero
that's what concave upward tells us
right because if this is greater than
zero then that means that the rate of
change of the slope is positive that's
what we said was concave upwards
now
in concave downwards the slope is
decreasing the rate of change of the
slope is decreasing or it's negative
so
in that case the second derivative would
be less than zero
and then in the situation where we're
switching if we're if over here let's
look at this situation we're concave
downwards
we're concave downwards over this
interval right here that means that the
second derivative derivative has to be
less than zero over this interval the
rate of change of the slope is negative
it's decreasing so over this interval
our second derivative is less than zero
but then we go concave upwards so our
second derivative has to be greater than
zero over this interval which implies if
our second derivative is continuous that
the second derivative had to be
had to be equal to zero at that point
and i'll do that with some examples in
future videos now this condition by
itself isn't enough to say that it's an
inflection point in order for something
to be an inflection a point the the
second derivative has to switch signs it
has to go from being negative and a
concave downward to positive and concave
upwards or it has to go from positive
and concave upwards to negative and
concave downwards and obviously in
between it's going to switch if you're
switching signs you're going to hit 0.
so when the second derivative is 0 it
might be an inflection point and then
you want to test around it to see if
it's actually switching signs and i'll
show you that in the next video but
hopefully you at least have an intuitive
sense of what inflection points look
like
and what the second derivative is
telling us if the slope is constantly
increasing then the rate of change of
slope is positive then the second
derivative is positive if the slope if
the rate if the slope is decreasing
then the rate of change of slope is
negative which tells us that the second
derivative is negative and the point in
which you're switching from negative
from a posit from a a positive second
derivative to a negative one or a
negative one to a positive one that is
what is called an inflection point